Un fait
a émergé du MIT
il y a deux ans.
Ken Hale, qui est spécialiste des langues étrangères,
a dit que sur les 6 000 langues
parlées en ce moment sur Terre,
3 000 ne sont pas parlées par les enfants.
De sorte qu'en une génération,
notre diversité culturelle va être réduite de moitié.
Il a ajouté
que tous les 15 jours,
un ancien rejoint la tombe
en emportant avec lui les derniers mots
de sa culture.
Alors toute une philosophie,
un ensemble de connaissances sur le monde naturel,
qui ont été rassemblées pendant des siècles,
tout cela disparaît.
Et cela survient toutes les deux semaines.
Depuis 20 ans,
après avoir été dentiste,
je voyage dans le monde
et je reviens
avec des histoires sur certains de ces peuples.
Et ce que j'aimerais faire maintenant,
c'est partager quelques-unes de ces histoires avec vous.
Voici Tamdin.
C'est une bonne sœur de 69 ans.
Elle a été jetée en prison au Tibet pendant deux ans
pour avoir brandi une toute petite affiche
pour protester contre l'occupation de son pays.
Quand je l'ai rencontrée,
elle venait de traverser l'Himalaya
depuis Lhasa, la capitale du Tibet,
jusqu'au Népal, et en Inde --
30 jours --
pour rencontrer son chef spirituel, le Dalaï-Lama.
Le Dalaï-Lama vit à Dharamsala, en Inde.
J'ai pris cette photo trois jours
après son arrivée,
et elle avait ces tennis usées aux pieds,
avec ses orteils qui dépassaient.
Elle a fait sa traversée au mois de mars,
et il y a beaucoup de neige à 5 600 m d'altitude en mars.
Voici Paldin.
Paldin est un moine de 62 ans.
Il a passé 33 ans en prison.
Tout son monastère a été emprisonné
lors du soulèvement,
quand le Dalaï-Lama a été forcé à quitter
le Tibet.
Et,
il était battu, il souffrait de faim,
il avait été torturé -- il a perdu toutes ses dents en prison.
Quand je l'ai rencontré, c'était un vieil homme doux et gentil.
Et ça m'a vraiment impressionné --
je l'ai rencontré deux semaines après sa sortie de prison --
qu'après avoir traversé toutes ces épreuves,
il finisse avec ce comportement.
J'étais donc à Dharamsala avec ces gens,
et j'y ai passé environ cinq semaines,
et j'entendais ces histoires semblables
de ces réfugiés qui avaient quitté le Tibet
pour Dharamsala.
Et il se trouve que lors de la cinquième semaine,
le Dalaï-Lama a fait une conférence publique.
Et il --
je regardais la foule de moines et de religieuses,
que pour beaucoup je venais d'interviewer,
et dont j'avais entendu les histoires,
et je regardais leurs visages,
et on nous avait donné une petite radio FM
pour qu'on puisse écouter ses enseignements.
Et il a dit :
« Traite tes ennemis comme des objets de valeur,
parce que ce sont tes ennemis
qui consolident ta résistance et ta patience
sur la voie de la sagesse. »
Et je ne pouvais pas -- ça m'a tellement touché,
de dire ça à ces gens qui avaient vécu ces souffrances.
Alors deux mois plus tard, je suis allé
au Tibet, et j'ai commencé
à y interroger les gens, à prendre des photos. C'est ce que je fais.
J'interroge et je prends des photos.
C'est une petite fille.
J'ai pris sa photo en haut du Jokhang Temple.
J'ai fait passer --
parce que c'est illégal de posséder la photo du Dalaï-Lama au Tibet ;
c'est la manière la plus rapide de se faire arrêter.
J'ai donc fait passer un paquet de petites photos du Dalaï-Lama,
et je les ai distribuées.
Et quand je les donnais aux gens,
ils les serraient contre leur cœur,
ou ils les gardaient au-dessus de leur tête pendant un moment.
Et c'est --
à cette époque -- j'ai fait ça il y a 10 ans --
c'était 36 ans après le départ du Dalaï-Lama.
Donc,
j'arrivais, j'interrogeais ces gens, et je les prenais en photo.
Voici Jigme et sa sœur, Sonam.
Elles vivent sur le Chang Tang, sur le plateau tibétain,
à l'extrême-ouest du pays.
C'est à 5 000 mètres d'altitude.
Elles venaient de redescendre des alpages,
à 5 500 mètres.
Même chose : je lui ai donné une photo,
elle l'a gardée sur son front.
Et d'habitude je distribue des Polaroids
quand je fais ça, parce que je règle la lumière,
et je vérifie l'éclairage,
et quand je lui ai montré le Polaroid, elle a crié et a couru dans sa tente.
Voici Tenzin Gyatso,
il a été reconnu Bouddha de la Compassion à l'âge de deux ans,
alors qu'il vivait dans une maison de paysans,
au milieu de nulle part.
A l'âge de quatre ans, il a été proclamé
14ème Dalaï-Lama.
A son adolescence, il a dû
faire face à l'invasion de son pays,
et il a dû s'en occuper -- il était le chef du pays.
Huit ans plus tard, quand on a découvert un complot
visant à l'assassiner,
ils lui ont mis des habits de pauvre
et l'ont fait sortir en douce du pays à dos de cheval,
et ils lui ont fait suivre le même parcours que Tamdin.
Et il vit -- il n'est jamais rentré dans son pays depuis.
Et
c'est incroyable de penser à cet homme,
qui, 46 ans plus tard,
conserve encore
cette réaction non-violente
face à un problème politique et de droits de l'Homme.
Et les jeunes,
les jeunes tibétains, commencent à dire : « Écoutez, ça ne marche pas. »
Vous savez, la violence en tant qu'arme politique
c'est le seul moyen en ce moment.
Et,
il campe sur ses positions.
Il est notre modèle
de non-violence dans notre monde --
une de nos icônes vivantes.
Voici un autre chef.
Voici Moi. C'est en Amazonie équatorienne.
Moi a 35 ans.
Et
dans cette région d'Amazonie équatorienne --
on y a découvert du pétrole en 1972.
Et depuis,
autant de pétrole, ou deux fois plus de pétrole,
qui a été répandu dans l'accident de l'Exxon Valdez,
s'est déversé dans cette petite région de l'Amazonie,
et les tribus locales ont dû constamment se déplacer.
Moi
appartient à la tribu Huaorani,
ils sont connus pour être
très violents, on les appelle les "Aucas".
Ils ont réussi à tenir à l'écart
les sismologues et les compagnies pétrolières
avec des lances et des sarbacanes.
J'ai passé,
on a passé -- j'étais avec une équipe --
deux semaines avec ces gens dans la jungle
à les regarder chasser.
C'était lors d'une chasse aux singes,
ils chassaient avec des fléchettes empoisonnées.
Le savoir que ces gens possèdent
sur l'environnement naturel est incroyable.
Ils pouvaient entendre, sentir, et voir des choses que je ne pouvais pas.
Je ne pouvais même pas voir les singes
qu'ils attrapaient
avec ces fléchettes.
Voici Yadira.
Yadira
a 5 ans. Elle vient d'une tribu
voisine des Huaorani.
Sa tribu a dû se déplacer
trois fois ces 10 dernières années à cause du pétrole.
Nous n'entendons jamais parler de ça. Et la dernière
violation faite à ce peuple,
qui fait partie du plan Colombia,
c'est qu'on vaporise des herbicides,
on déboise des milliers d'hectares
en Amazonie équatorienne
dans notre guerre contre la drogue.
Et c'est gens en font les frais.
Voici Mengatoue.
C'est le chaman des Huaorani,
et il --
il nous a dit : « Je suis un vieillard maintenant,
je suis fatigué, j'en ai assez
de repousser ces compagnies pétrolières,
j'aimerais juste qu'elles s'en aillent. »
D'habitude je voyage seul
quand je travaille, mais là je faisais --
j'accueillais une émission pour Discovery,
et quand je suis arrivé avec mon équipe,
j'étais assez inquiet à l'idée
d'aller voir la tribu Huaorani avec tout un tas de personnes,
notamment chez les Huaorani.
Et,
il s'est avéré que ces personnes m'ont vraiment
appris plusieurs choses sur l'art de se fondre
avec les autochtones.
(Rires)
Une chose que j'ai faite
juste avant les attentats du 11 septembre --
en août 2001 --
j'ai emmené mon fils, Dax,
qui avait 16 ans à l'époque,
je l'ai emmené au Pakistan.
Parce que je voulais --
je l'avais déjà emmené en voyage,
mais je voulais qu'il voit
les gens qui vivent avec moins d'un dollar par jour.
Je voulais qu'il connaisse
le monde musulman
et je voulais aussi qu'il --
j'y allais pour travailler avec un groupe,
faire un reportage sur un groupe appelé le Kalash.
Il s'agit d'un groupe d'animistes, d'environ 3000 personnes
qui vivent dans une toute petite région
entourée par l'Islam. Il ne reste que 3000
de ces Kalash, ce sont vraiment des gens incroyables.
C'était une expérience géniale pour lui. Il est resté debout toute la nuit avec eux,
à jouer du tambour et à danser.
Il avait apporté un ballon de foot,
et on a joué au foot tous les soirs dans ce petit village.
Et puis on s'est levé
pour rencontrer leur chaman.
D'ailleurs, Mangatoue aussi
était le chaman de sa tribu.
Voici John Doolikahn,
le chaman des Kalash.
Il vit dans les montagnes,
juste à la frontière avec l'Afghanistan.
En fait, de l'autre côté, il y a Tora Bora,
la région où
Oussama Ben Laden est censé se trouver. C'est la région tribale.
Nous avons regardé
et nous sommes restés avec
John Doolikahn.
Le chaman -- j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le chamanisme,
c'est un phénomène
très intéressant.
Mais dans le monde,
ils entrent en transe de différentes manières.
Et au Pakistan,
pour entrer en transe, ils brûlent des feuilles de genévrier,
ils sacrifient un animal,
versent le sang de l'animal sur les feuilles
et inhalent la fumée.
Ils prient tous
les dieux de la montagne
lorsqu'ils entrent en transe.
Vous savez,
c'est important d'habituer les enfants à des réalités différentes.
Ce que Dan Dennett a dit l'autre jour --
avoir étudié différentes religions,
juste pour avoir une plus grande souplesse mentale --
ça leur donne aussi une souplesse mentale
dans d'autres systèmes de croyances.
Je pense que c'est une nécessité dans notre monde aujourd'hui
alors qu'on assiste à toutes ses luttes entre croyances.
Et tous les problèmes de sécurité qu'elles nous causent.
Il y a cinq ans, nous avons créé
un programme qui connecte des enfants
de communautés indigènes à des enfants aux États-Unis.
D'abord on a lié
une communauté Navajo à une classe à Seattle.
On a maintenant 15 sites.
On a en a un à Katmandou, au Népal ;
à Dharamsala, en Inde ; à Takaungu, au Kenya --
Takaungu est à 1/3 chrétienne, 1/3 musulmane,
et 1/3 animiste.
Ollantaytambo, au Pérou,
et Arctic Village, en Alaska.
Voici Daniel, un de nos élèves
à Arctic Village, en Alaska.
Il vit dans cette cabane en bois.
Sans eau courante, sans chauffage,
sans fenêtres,
mais avec l'Internet haut-débit.
Et voici --
je vois ce genre de déploiement informatique partout --
c'est notre site à Ollantaytambo, au Pérou, il y a quatre ans,
lorsqu'ils ont vu pour la première fois un ordinateur ;
maintenant, ils ont des ordinateurs dans leurs classes.
Et la façon dont on a fait ça --
nous avons appris à ces enfants à raconter numériquement des histoires.
Et nous leur avons parlé des problèmes de leur communauté,
leur communauté à laquelle ils tiennent.
C'est au Pérou, où les enfants ont raconté l'histoire
de la rivière qu'ils ont nettoyée.
Pour faire cela, nous avons des ateliers,
et nous y amenons des gens qui veulent apprendre
les techniques numériques et la mise en image de leurs histoires,
et nous les faisons travailler
avec les enfants.
Plus tôt cette année, nous avons amené en groupe d'adolescents,
et ça a fonctionné à merveille.
Notre rêve est donc de rassembler les adolescents,
pour qu'ils vivent une expérience collective d'entraide
ainsi qu'une expérience interculturelle,
en instruisant les enfants de ces régions
et en les aidant à construire leurs moyens de communication.
Nous voici en train d'apprendre Photoshop
aux enfants tibétains du village de Dharamsala.
Nous avons un site Internet, où les enfants possèdent leur page personnelle.
Voici leurs films. Nous avons environ 60 films
que ces enfants ont réalisés,
et ils sont vraiment incroyables.
Celui que je veux vous montrer --
après les avoir incités à faire les films,
nous avons passé une soirée à regarder les films de la communauté.
Là, c'est à Takaungu --
nous avons un générateur de courant et un projecteur numérique,
et nous les projetons sur les murs d'une grange,
et nous montrons un des films qu'ils ont fait.
Et si vous en avez l'occasion, vous pouvez visiter notre site Internet, et vous verrez
le travail fantastique de ces enfants.
Ces enfants -- une autre chose :
je voulais donner une voix aux peuples indigènes.
C'était l'un des grands facteurs déclencheurs.
Mais l'autre facteur déclencheur
vient des vues étroites de notre pays.
Le National Geographic a mené une étude
auprès des 18-26 ans
dans notre pays
et dans neuf autres pays industrialisés.
C'était une étude à deux millions de dollars.
Les États-Unis se sont classés avant-derniers
en connaissances géographiques.
70% des jeunes n'ont pas trouvé
l'Afghanistan ou l'Irak sur une carte,
60% n'ont pas trouvé l'Inde ;
30% n'ont pas trouvé l'océan Pacifique.
Et c'est une étude
qui a été faite il y a seulement deux ans.
Ce que j'aimerais vous montrer maintenant,
dans les quelques minutes qui me restent,
c'est un film réalisé par un étudiant du Guatemala.
Nous avions un atelier au Guatemala.
Une semaine avant d'y aller,
un énorme glissement de terrain, causé par l'ouragan Stan,
en octobre dernier, s'est abattu et a enterré vivantes
600 personnes dans leur village.
Et cet enfant vivait dans le village --
il n'était pas sur place lorsque c'est arrivé --
et voici la vidéo qu'il a montée à ce sujet.
Et il n'avait pas vu d'ordinateur avant
que nous fassions cette vidéo. Nous lui avons appris Photoshop et --
oui, on peut la lancer.
C'est un ancien chant funèbre Maya
qu'il tient de son grand-père.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)